E
OF STAPLES CENTER TO INTRODUCE
THE TRIBUTE TO THE CARU-SHOW,
CHAMPION FOR THE LAKERS.
>> ALEX CARUSO!
TURN YOUR ATTENTION NOW TO THE
VIDEO BOARD FOR A SPECIAL
TRIBUTE.
♪
>> THIS IS THE PERSON THAT
COMPETES WITH THEIR HEAD AS WELL
AS THEIR BODY.
>> KICKOUT, CARUSO, FOR THE
LEAD!
GOT IT TO GO.
>> GOES UP, SLAM IT DOWN!
ALEX CARUSO WITH THE FLUSH.
>> CAPPING A RIDE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES LAKERS.
>> NEXT MAN UP, IT IS THE NBA.
I AM JUST TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY.
>> HE CAN GO TO THE RIM, HE DOES
IT AGAIN!
>> LOOK AT LEBRON!
>> HE DOES NOT MAKE MANY
MISTAKES ON THE FLOOR.
HE PLAYS GREAT BASKETBALL.
IT IS JUST WHO HE IS.
>> HE IS DOING WHAT HE IS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
HE COMES IN, LIMITED MINUTES, HE
WREAKS HAVOC AND FANS LOVE HIM.
>> KICK IT OUT TO ALEX, THE
THREE IS ON ITS WAY.
>> CARUSO, ANOTHER THREE!
>> BUTTER ON A HOT DOG?
[LAUGHTER]
>> HERE COMES CARUSO!
>> WELCOME TO THE PLAYOFFS!
>> CARUSO FOR THREE.
>> BLOCKED I CARUSO.
>> --BY CARUSO.
>> HE DUNKED IT!
>> TO BE HERE NOW, THREE OR FOUR
YEARS LATER, IT IS REALLY
FULFILLING.
IT MAKES IT SO WORTH IT.
♪
>> LAKER NATION, LAKER WORLD --
WELCOME BACK LAKER WORLD
CHAMPION, ALEX CARUSO!